finally we have some footage of the one
piece live action series and I have some
thoughts some good some great and some
not so great let's get into it honestly
this whole project is such an insane
thing to even attempt that I'm doing my
very best to reserve judgment till I see
the whole thing for myself when it is
officially released rather than a minute
long trailer but there is one line in
particular that stuck the most to me and
that is this all going to Fighters call
out their finishing moves
no they don't I am really not pressing
judgment on this show at all right now
because a single trailer edited together
by a marketing department is not going
to be a good representation of the final
products quality good or bad but that
line does worry me following up an
attack by lamb shading the Trope is just
I don't know I really hope that this
show isn't embarrassed of its source
material that it can manage to be
unabashedly one piece and bring these
beloved characters and stories to life
for a new audience to enjoy and I still
think that's very possible